this morning we returned to the hills of
paso robles in central california where
this spectacular art installation look
at that that's spectacular beautiful
field of light was created by artist
bruce monroe now this opened back in
2019 and it was supposed to be a
temporary exhibit but then the pandemic
hit and the owners of this outdoor venue
decided hey people need a place to
escape and decompress more than ever
they're right about that jamie yukas
first visited when it opened back then
she then reconnected with the artist
this summer to explore the new addition
to his expanding work of art
[Music]
shimmering and shining more than 58 000
solar-powered spheres make a dazzling
display on this california night
hopefully the art
helps you see nature and nature helps
you see the arts combining nature and
technology british artist bruce monroe
created the field of light in paso
robles california
amazingly i think people do feel a sense
of peace and connection because that's
my intention
[Music]
when the pandemic hit the real power of
this immersive experience came to light
stressed out visitors found a place for
meditation and a renewed sense of
serenity
why do you think people connect so
strongly to your work because i think
they're simple when one feels connected
with a time and place
you feel open you sort of dissolve and
you stop being eye and you become part
of something much bigger
life is so short
so i kind of thought it's time to just
raise your hand and say look
good stuff does happen
the good stuff starts as the sun sets
people gather to watch the spectacular
super bloom come to life
it's expanded now to include 69 light
towers composed of more than 17 000 wine
bottles a nod to the area's surrounding
vineyards the colors change in unison to
a musical score
how does it make you feel
alive i'd say alive do you have certain
feelings that come up when you look at
all the lights
i feel really happy
and i feel like
nothing bad is ever going to happen
again when times get dark
you just have to open up your eyes and
see the light seeing the light became
critical in paso robles when the
pandemic shut down fundraisers for local
charities so the venue started hosting
events and donating money to several
groups struggling to survive
first after covid then with supply
issues and now inflation this is mini
cooper leslie thomas runs a nearby
animal sanctuary a permanent home to 43
furry friends
all with special needs now horses are
being dumped because of feed costs the
animals are taking the brunt of
the economy but it's our joy we love it
we're going to keep them forever make
sure they're healthy you can't believe
how we use that money and we helped a
lot of families fantastic and the money
raised has been life-changing for john
allen's organization which helps the
families of law enforcement pay medical
costs not covered by insurance
this officer injured in a shootout in
2020 is still unable to return to work
when we help somebody it's unbelievably
they call they're crying and we're
crying and it's just an amazing program
it's just showing people really do care
and people have got
big hearts and we should be looking out
for each other
monroe was looking out for hospital
workers while isolating at home in
england in 2020 he built a ribbon of
light along the edge of his property
with some 60 000 cds a footpath to raise
both money and the spirits of medical
teams and volunteers
light is an easy way to
heal the spirit there's a lot of healing
still to go on
and i hope that the installations
that i create do bring some joy to
people's hearts
bruce monroe's magical illuminations
have been a welcoming beacon around the
world for close to 20 years
leading with light he hopes the beauty
grounds you in the moment
in some ways there has been light coming
out of that darkness it's allowed us to
rediscover our values our core values
we must remember
what we were like
for the pandemic and how much we've
learned from it
to make us better people and live more
fulfilled lives
for cbs mornings i'm jamie yukas in paso
robles california
[Music]
i'm now trying to figure out exactly
where is paso robles how close is that
what's the little girl saying she said
she feels really happy and it feels like
nothing bad is going to happen again we
got to go there i want to go there all
right i also like the guy though nate
who said when he looks at the lights it
makes him feel alive that's right